so now socialist democrats tonight
they're continuing to plot
their far left takeover a future quote
they hope by the administration
eager to push doom gloom dark winner joe
as far left as possible and unleash what
will
predictably based on their stated
policies be a destructive
progressive agenda on you the american
people now remember joe biden
already put these far left promises all
in writing remember the
biden bernie manifesto this summer now
here's what comrade bernie had to say
about
all of this on fake news cnn promises
made
but do i expect that they will come
forward and keep their word
uh in in uh maintaining
uh and legislating on the proposals
which we agreed to yes i do investing
two trillion dollars
in combating climate change and creating
millions of jobs
as we move away from fossil fuel to
energy efficiency and sustainable energy
so would i have gone further yes are
those significant proposals
that will protect the needs of working
families yes they are
now that was followed up by
congresswoman california congresswoman
maxine waters claiming biden is ushering
in the new
dawn of a new progressive era take a
look
on november 3rd america decisively
rejected president trump
his harmful policies and his dangerous
rhetoric
the american people have given president
elect biden
a mandate to govern and reverse the
harmful
policies of the trump administration we
are merging from the dark days
of the trump administration into the
dawn of a new progressive
america and not to be outdone fellow
socialist
elizabeth warren also praising the biden
harris agenda
calling it the most progressive economic
platform
ever far left filmmaker michael moore is
now amplifying calls to abolish the
electoral college
so new york california new jersey
illinois they will pick your president
every four years
let's be clear this new extreme
radical democratic socialist and even
lawless party
they're on a quest for power at all
costs
and they're vowing to destroy anyone and
everyone that dares to get in their way
including members of their own party for
example
look at this tweet that was sent out
by the real speaker of the house
congresswoman ocasio-cortez showing
her staring down west virginia senator
joe manchin
in response to his tweet slamming this
whole defund the police movement
insanity
even nancy pelosi cannot avoid the wrath
of this new crop of progressive radicals
as far left groups now this week slammed
the speaker
over her now infamous ice cream stunt
remember in the spring
calling it an unforced error
that hurt the party's messaging and led
to unexpected
losses for democrats in the house last
week pelosi schumer
biden are under more pressure than ever
to surrender to socialist extremists
inside their party
from policy to personnel this crop of
radicals they're not interested in any
compromise
we know they have no desire for real
civility
we've watched them the last four years
they want cabinet positions
they want top influence they want all
the power no matter what it takes
and it's why all eyes are on the state
of georgia
why this election january 5th yeah is
very important
that would be for david perdue and kelly
loffler
to ensure that well they're in office in
january
you keep the senate and republican hands
as some check
as some balance because we need to stop
this power grab
right now or say hello to
let's say two new states four new
democratic senators
democratic majority in the senate
possibly in perpetuity
packing the court no more electoral
college and yes
more doom gloom dark winter lockdowns
because get this one of joe biden's
coveted advisors
already scheming to implement a
nationwide four to six week lockdown
that would further decimate the economy
and the lives of working men and women
and it's even worse you got another
advisor dr ziki manuel
he wants any vaccine to be first
distributed globally
across the world i guess what america
last
instead of fellow citizens here in the
u.s well that sounds like
yep america in last place and meanwhile
new york governor andrew cuomo
continuing to play politics with a
life-saving vaccine suggesting
he won't even accept distribution of a
vaccine developed under the trump
administration
without a separate review process